bitcoin is a decentralized currency and
there's lots of people who are wondering
how will it perform in a time where we
may go into a recession well in order to
understand how it could perform first we
need to understand how it has performed
bitcoin over the last 13 years has
served as a non-correlated asset it
allowed for investors to go ahead and
buy it put it into their portfolio and
provide a positive impact on their
financial returns
as they pursued a risk mitigated
asymmetric return investors were very
happy with having that exposure to
bitcoin but now it seems that we
actually have two different types of
bitcoin holders first is the wall street
institution world bitcoin is the most
risky asset that they actually own
and then there's the everyday average
citizen bitcoin is their reserve asset
they continue to just dollar cost
average in the bitcoin regardless of
what happens in the world
now the reason why this is important is
because if we go into a recession
ultimately the people who treat bitcoin
as a risk asset they're likely to sell
it along with every other risk asset in
their portfolio but the people that
treat bitcoin as a reserve asset they're
likely to continue to dollar cost
average and simply hold on to what they
think is the most pristine asset in
their portfolio so if we go ahead and we
take a look has bitcoin been correlated
to risk assets or not well there's brand
new data coming out this morning that
you should pay attention to we've got
this tweet here from lawrence mcdonald
where he says that since 2020 bitcoin's
been tied at the hip with the nasdaq 100
index the 40-day correlation just
reached a brand new record high
bloomberg reporting that increases in
this correlation further erode the
argument that bitcoin works well as a
diversifier one that's been held up by
proponents as key to its appeal and if
we go ahead and we take a look yes
bitcoin and the nasdaq reaching all-time
highs but if you look back there the
green and red going up and down up and
down in correlation because bitcoin was
a non-correlated asset for a long time
maybe that's changing maybe it's not if
we then go ahead and we take a look you
can look at somebody like arthur hayes
the founder of bitmex in which he states
there are many crypto market pundits who
believe the worst is over i believe they
ignore the inconvenient truth that
crypto prices are currently an indicator
for the s p 500 and nasdaq 100 and do
not trade on the fundamentals of being
peer-to-peer decentralized
censorship-resistant digital networks
designed for the transfer of money
now arthur is looking at bitcoin as an
investment asset he's saying what are
investors going to do do they treat this
like their growth stocks like their tech
stocks or do they actually look at it as
a non-correlated asset today
the influx of new investor types since
2020 has changed a lot of what's going
on in the bitcoin market what happens
from here is anyone's guess
but one of the key takeaways is that you
have to have an open mind you have to
constantly re-evaluate your perspective
things change quickly in bitcoin in
crypto industry and this is just one
more data point that suggests that the
holder-based changing may actually be
changing the way that the asset performs
in certain situations as the fed
continues to increase their interest
rates and look to try to get inflation
under control
my guess is that we're increasing the
probability of a recession if people
fear a recession coming they're not
going to wait for it to occur before
they move their money and that's
probably why we're seeing a good amount
of cell pressure on an asset like
bitcoin which based on the wall street
institutional world bitcoin is their
risk asset and they're treating it just
like that as those recession fears grow
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time